what has been your biggest screwup as a
designers I have a tendency to make
screw-ups they're almost like everyday I
was eight I absolutely love what I do I
am what I need to be in order to make my
ideas come true I love creating and
every day is totally different that
great design sells itself it doesn't
they kind of think it's just having
ideas or sketches it's actually more
about meeting a lot of people capacity
of curiosity and observation first
curiosity comes before creativity if
you're not the curious person you're
never going to have creative solutions
ability to do research and your ability
to see detail a capacity of freedom in
your interpretation being able to talk
to business talk as well you have to be
able to communicate what you have
created and get other people to help you
execute on it guilty as charged this is
not black just for the record this is a
very very dark blue I don't know we're
lazy we don't like to dry clean
everything in life that we use has been
designed it's gone through the hands and
eyes of a designer the world needs
change the ones who could leave that
change is a designer who knows his way
around outer design change I was kicked
out of fine art school twice but you
need to go anyway there's a mix of
skills that the design team needs you
need one of those skills have to learn
to unlearn to fail that's what a good
school teaches you obviously you have to
break all these rules you get and then
create your own what path oh oh there's
so many I was actually doing inflatable
furniture which was called IKEA air is
one of the biggest mistakes in my case
history I somehow ended up pushing into
the market an idea that was really more
conceptual it was a very good idea but
it failed because I didn't take it to
that next level of fine-tuning it
for me the biggest problem has been that
I've been educated in the society that
told the materials of the process there
were no sustainable we have to work a
lot and to rethink about our relations
with our planet
stay young because when you're young
you're not fed up with stuff you're
still hungry have confidence in yourself
there are always people telling you it's
not possible or it's not allowed you
completely ignore them
just relax go with your gut because
usually your gut is right take ownership
of your own ideas of your own life and
although it's a bit abstract and blurred
in the beginning if you put the idea
central if you let the idea guide you it
will take you so much
[Music]